last week I was home Tom Segura them you
know I would never kill me Boulevard and
we stopped at a light the beauty Tom
Segura I want to do this but I want to
do this for your studio only I only want
Tom Segura productions about a camera
can't [ __ ] do with the glasses yeah
Josh box yeah let's get him let's go
nice and snow we rent the car in New
York he drives down Kelly Boulevard I
tell you every corner where I rob
somebody
it is the [ __ ] funniest thing I used
to rob a gas station across the school
from high school what there was a gas
station across the street nice group is
a Cuban guy named George so the gas
stations in an amicus we just call from
Georgie amico that was his name let's
started out alright but I could see that
he was a dick so what might wanted to
rob a gas station me and my buddy Ramos
got rest his soul
so the first time we robbed it we didn't
really robbed it I went down trying to
rob a water pistol from Pathmark and I
got caught robbing the water pistol
because you put tape around huh and it
was second a [ __ ] thing I got caught
and I talked my way out of it so we went
we got like another plastic gun from my
friends [ __ ] little brother and we
taped it up and we me and radio we're
gonna rob the joint and we went in and
the [ __ ] dude was washing his hands
and he had the bundle of money on top of
the counter you can't write this [ __ ]
can't write this [ __ ] and I remember
looking at ayran and I just grabbed him
he just ran like [ __ ] down the corner
we ran for like three [ __ ] box one
box full speed ahead we get to the
corner there's nothing there's gots it
was a Jewish bankroll it was like a
twenty with a bunch of singles no guys
so now we wait like six months and
there's a new attendant and this guy he
went in there full speed ahead my
[ __ ] baseball bat broke the glass we
grabbed him give me your [ __ ] money
who took them we had masks on which
keyholes and the whole [ __ ] thing we
took him that time yeah I like the small
eight we got him good cuz in Jersey they
got to pump your gas yeah so they keep
the [ __ ] money so we always knew this
[ __ ] so we shook him down and then we
did that to him in another time you had
a bunch of tires out there and we just
went one night with a
just try putting tires in the Claudia
took all the tires there was no cameras
in this day that's one used to rap with
a woman with how often were you robbing
places I would alternate them I had a
couple different spots that I would just
hit them when they were weak yeah so
don't you miss that a little bit Oh with
all my heart I see [ __ ] I see so many
openings now but this cameras everywhere
because it's in your blood
I'm sayin yeah but unless the thrill
right it's gotta be such a thrill so we
kept robbing this guy ty is you know the
whole thing soda machine the other soda
machine we broke it one night we just
this guy you called the cops the cops
are like we know these guys we can't
arrest these kids yeah we had to be 16
17 and no one at the tire shop said 16
year olds was hired from our tires no no
we would move [ __ ] like [ __ ] we had a
guy that we would but the guy got so
angry he called the cops so much he
cross the street and he's dark feet
started talking to the superintendent of
schools and the superintendent of
schools we grew up in his house too
and he was like chunky a guy he looked
like Pauly from Goodfellas I'm not that
seen the guy telling them complaining
these kids you gotta calm him down and
he would say and Miss that I don't want
to say his name got arrested so mr.
Haywood have a cigar D go I talk to them
all the time but they don't listen just
like that just like that waiting some
[ __ ] podcast Ville it's Monday
May 13th wash your [ __ ] and powder your
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's gonna be a good
[ __ ] week the Church of what's
happening now is brought to you by
manscaped listen let me tell you
something there's nothing worse than
trimming your nutsack and around the
[ __ ] pole of death and you're gonna
sit there and look around and have
anxiety oh you gotta ask your wife to
[ __ ] trim your [ __ ] nutsack it's
not good but the suffering ends today oh
that's it mother's days over it's
Father's Day you got to keep even your
daddy 70 years old what healing think he
gives your mom a little due to roots
from time to time give a little Father's
Day here say get some of this [ __ ] nut
sack
you got the precision tools and you got
a penny there for the family jewels
manscape has redesigned the electric
razor with the lawnmower
and he'll razor with skin-safe
technology that won't Nick or snag your
[ __ ] nut sack all right you gotta go
easy on the [ __ ] Pole of debt so do
me a favor at manscape comm you get
everything you need to make your boss
shine and your dick looking pretty
[ __ ] good too you know I'm saying so
the church family gets 20% off with your
first order when you use promo code
church at manscape calm
that's promo code church at manscape
calm remember keep your balls clean the
church is also brought to you by CBD
Lyon listen no more [ __ ] CBD oils and
liquor stores okay I see a Hindu selling
CBD and [ __ ] bottles of vodka I like
the place I'm fine it's not [ __ ] easy
no more CBD lions got your cupboard
shattered paper pens [ __ ] attention
that you put under your tongue listen no
more walking around saw not nothing I
got your CBD line back down go to that
website right now and check out their
third party lab results for your [ __ ]
self and just for checking I'm gonna
throw you a little gift the church
family gets 20 [ __ ] percent off
on checkout that CBD lion calm kick this
[ __ ] meal wait Tommy buns in
the [ __ ] house I'll say it fast I'll
say how are you I'm great man now when
you see a dead you speak Spanish damn it
oh no my dad doesn't my mom your mom
yeah what'd she say to you in Spanish
anything items he talking with you know
what if I what Ivan bear so you know
call that show that [ __ ] everything man
she speaks to me oh you know pretty much
50/50 a lot of Spanglish so did you take
Spanish in high school
I did I was but I was through it all
like what I passed a level 4 AP
sophomore year so then they threw me in
French I got a D what a [ __ ]
nightmare that sounds gonna be as easy
as Spanish and I was like you never
switch you gotta keep in a neighborhood
yeah she's gotta tell you was Italian
yeah took Italian it was I can
understand that
yeah telling it was funny I was watching
The Godfather last night and thus more
South you go on the boot the more
Spanish she gets really yeah like when
you listen to Salah so talk he's pretty
much speaking Spanish too
he was [ __ ] like I forget what the
line I go wow it's so close and but I
grew up with Sicilians and when they
would talk picked up I could pick up a
[ __ ] nothing you can understand a lot
of it a lot of it yeah yeah and I hold
on then it gets a little then it gets a
little complicated
yeah the French like I said it's like
some guys say buongiorno mmm I like
northern Italy and maybe my don't quote
me on this I don't know but other people
say get far
that's hello so I think that's more of a
Sicilian violife you know yeah well then
what the [ __ ] do I know you ever heard
you ever spoken with like a real you
know Argentine and you're like are you
speaking Italian and it takes you a
second to realize they're speaking
Spanish well this is they setting it you
know thing this it's like speaking of
Spaniards yeah people that are really
from Spain the Spanish will complicate
but right now at this point the game
Segura I could maintain a simple
conversation the [ __ ] I was talking when
I was 13 has disappeared from my mind
yeah
like when I was 13 I was dropping
scientific facts in Spanish yeah I could
talk to my mother in a more once they
died that whole world died you know I
miss from Union City where you spoke
Spanish ie the Cuban spoke Spanish from
there amongst themselves so you earned
it you heard the music you know I
remember it and I'm happy that I
remember but it's not like and it was
proven when I went on the road and
processed 400 I didn't know a lot of
this [ __ ] he was saying common words
that is simple but I picked up after I
listened to the podcast so it's like a
muscle that it goes away it goes away
you know I I used to be really sharp at
one point when I when I was in college I
did a semester in Madrid and when I came
back from them right in term papers in
Spanish
giving presentations and I came back and
I'm not [ __ ] you my Spanish was
better than like my mom was then other
natives because I was just so immersed
in it you know I was Madrid six months
six months yeah how was it I was dope
dude I love Madrid how was the
amazing market everybody said it's
amazing yeah
seafood inspired everything a lot yeah
everything I mean but like the Spanish
cuisine is I mean I think it's
phenomenal so yeah it was yeah a lot of
seed footmouse all the pee all the
famous little high schools so good yeah
it's so good when I was in Jersey this
last time there's a ban you can't
compare it does a place called West
hoppers on Bergen wine Avenue and I
wasn't there to [ __ ] pay it was great
yeah but my all-time favorite paying it
back there is a dump
it's always like that no donkey in New
Jersey we're [ __ ] for some reason
everybody's head is just huge
hold on hey you know every time you see
people walking like that time to carry
their head some lap with the water that
giant stadium something I don't even
know mu luck he has a high school and
they would have blown it up like that I
don't [ __ ] know but they got a
[ __ ] pie and it's dirty a violin CL
you gotta give him 45 minute notice and
then you gotta warm up cuz you got the
shrimp with the garlic yeah and you got
to dip the bread in the garlic if not it
just doesn't [ __ ] work I like when
you scrape that pan that garlic play all
my rice rice man I just went I had the
clannish you know Salazar basically our
appetizer yeah [ __ ] like that but it's
funny my mother used to she said that my
mother told me she had to do like and I
can't do the time line like what she
trying to figure it out now my mother
had to do like a six months
apprenticeship with my grandmother on my
father's side because they were from
Spain and she had him spoiled rotten
with what how she cooking her yeah so
that was part of the deal to get married
to him you got another cook cook for him
whoa
so my father had some old-school [ __ ]
yeah so when my father died my mother
kept cooking those meals and there was a
fish soup that she made that nobody's
ever made because she would take the
fish and break it into little strands to
take the bones out with potatoes or some
female mm-hm you like when you profile a
oh it's noodles
wilfy there was something completely
different yeah and when you have female
you know you have a [ __ ] free there
and did your dad die in Cuba no he died
mune City he did he died in Union City
and how how much before your mother did
he 13 years 13 years before should I
didn't you did you remember your dad I
can't lie to you sessions like I'm a two
stories I heard them being him driving
under Lincoln Tunnel with me sitting on
his lap which you couldn't do it away no
seatbelt smoking cigarette yeah he'll
throw you in jail for that
oh yeah I remember him and my mother
talking in the living room like very and
me and bread with olive oil like that
but that's it I don't remember nothing
else yeah it's [ __ ] sickening that I
feel his presence like whenever I leave
the house you know I worry about my
daughter you know he thirty [ __ ] five
school shootings this year it's crazy
you know you see that little young kids
face do you see the one [ __ ] 12 year
old they say I get a bat bag now and
that's how these kids gotta be yeah they
interviewed a 12 year old kids in the
Colorado shooting this past weekend and
the kid was like I'll take a bat or
whatever you think you gotta bad yeah I
don't want to go down I'm not gonna go
down unless I'm swinging and that's you
know and that's I'm trying
how old is your old this Elvis now he is
a three and a half three half not too
moist or not to worry and then they go
to kindergarten Road there's a school
shooting and you know well there's a
school shooting in Kentucky it affects
all of us yeah of course
no it's terrible you know it's amazing
how people don't have kids I've dumped
my whole view with chains on kids I've
always loved kids anyway like I always
I'm not Michael Jackson invite him to
the house no but yeah the Great
Adventure was a great yeah but I like
kids I'm talking somewhere like
observing kids where the hell is that
you know and all that [ __ ] happen before
you grieve for the parents thank you
like I would hate to be you know no
parent should have to bury their child
now you know so you grieve about all
that [ __ ] but at the same time the how
mercy goes to school and now when I'm on
the road or whatever
you have to [ __ ] prepare you have to
prepare them like I've already shot a
gun in front of her just to see if she'd
should have pants you know just you have
to prepare them man it's a different
[ __ ] world and I got to tell you
something if anybody should have shot up
a school it would have been a guy like
me that lost his mother at 17 that
[ __ ] was really confused I was angry
at the world you know there's God that
they talk to me about the [ __ ] 15
years where the [ __ ] is it yeah there's
no God would remove his mother from this
kid right and I would never think of
blowing in at that age first of all this
is my place of business
yeah that's why I sold my ass I'm gonna
shoot up my own joint you know that my
own joint yeah
so I just it just doesn't just doesn't
make [ __ ] sense to me with it now the
[ __ ] shooting thing is so goddamn
depressing man you see did you see the
[ __ ] gun raid in Holmby Hills yeah
release Holmby Hills that's that's a
Beverly Hills Bel Air adjacent like
right there it's big time money and they
[ __ ] found a thousand guns
I saw Shih Tzu jugs like rifles assault
rifles all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ]
got more guns a Lincoln yeah [ __ ] was
going to war I use a white supremacist
think I haven't really released much
info you know in the house there's the
Getty one of the daughters of the Getty
wanna tell you something that's not
right by the way how [ __ ] upsetting
is it that the okay symbol has been
hijacked like that now that's an
supremacist thing do you know that I
don't even know what the okay symbol is
that dad is considered it's a flying
[ __ ] like yeah well where I came from
look at it that's an [ __ ] that's what
this was
you're just um a okay no and then the
the South Americans were all like this
means you're gay so they're like this
means you what you want some dick in
your ass
always been picking yeah yeah put it
take if you're standing on the corner
and some guy pulls up at the line goes
like this yeah he's asking yeah I wanna
dick me in the fall he's giving you
three fingers small three hundred when I
was a game like if you've got someone to
see you got to punch him that was the
game was a game but now yeah now it's
would you play these games with I don't
know a little [ __ ] [ __ ] kids I guess
it means [ __ ] in the ass
yeah and this means a flying [ __ ] but
now it means white [ __ ] power
you remember your first blow job yeah
what was the guy's name experiment you
do some gay [ __ ] no not even a little
bit not even you think of the bother no
no no he's gonna Gabe Osmond [ __ ] not
yet I know the mother levees young never
had like a tennis coach he's like now
you gotta do it like this I was a chubby
kid no one ever did that's a documentary
on that soccer coach it's a no no I
caught the first [ __ ] out of it
and I had to turn in love because I
could see my wife's jaw dropping yeah
like some [ __ ] molester the dude the
[ __ ] coach of the Olympics oh wait
the ethics code documentary on guy he
was opening up your [ __ ] and putting
two fingers and telling you it was
helping you yeah I was helping so if you
fin do your hips tight let me shake my
hand and you [ __ ] with no [ __ ]
ointment on my nothin he's like you
[ __ ] doing it it's like hundreds of
my or it's Jesus Christ hey you know
that's another one too you hear about
that and you're like [ __ ] amen
it's so depressing [ __ ] scary [ __ ]
the world and you gotta prepare yourself
well I know it's like for you Joe you
always go to your daughter's events it
seems like like it seems like it seems
weird to send your kid in an uber to an
event just with some random come on what
no way there's a lot more yeah don't get
me started don't get me started
you can't get me started with this [ __ ]
now I don't
I mean nicely in this where we live this
area is very I don't know I don't know
you know for years I was angry of my
mother
like in my early thirties when I went to
prison I wasn't angry with my mother I
just thought that she didn't do a good
job now I would open the casket and suck
one of the bones on her feet because she
did a phenomenal job and here's the sad
thing she was a degenerate gamma was
pretty much baseline of a functioning
alcoholic she could do more as an
alcoholic than most people do straight
she would eat people's [ __ ] lunches
yeah as a woman she ate people's once
she ate man's lunches never mind these
Kunti women that complain all day and on
through death yeah so now I have a big
time because the reason I'm in this room
at 56 is because of the principles that
she exposed me telling the little things
she did my mother worked till 3:00 in
the morning dog and my mother believed
that a bartender had a drink to sell
drinks my mother believed she had
business principle she's like I don't
want a bartender Andre you have to drink
when you're behind the bar was the 60s
and 70s you know so she really bought
she really believed that she believed
that she believed not her bartenders
could not have their boyfriends at the
bar if your boyfriend shows up you're
fired not a key I don't ever want the
illusion that that guy doesn't have a
chance with you right smart you know I
went to Benihana that day I got back in
New York I look at businesses and I
looked at what a waste they are that
Benihana Nancy no this is get off as
I've ever seen a place in my life I was
embarrassed papers on the floor there
was two drink cocktails outside and
scene it was a white neighborhood yeah
and it was disgusting but it wasn't the
people for it was that they did not hire
somebody to greet people at the door my
mother was she had that bar you know
what the biggest lesson I learned was I
don't feel when I was working for my
mother she would pay me good money 20
bucks ten bucks to do menial [ __ ] clean
the bathroom picked up and I'll never
forget one day we had the restaurant
still I had to be mercies age and we had
the restaurant still
and I still remember my mother and you
think about you listen to the story and
you might think it's the wrong thing I
mean my mother grabbed me go go put his
shirt on and a jagged I'm like what are
you talking about she's like come on
come on and there was a podium at my
mother's bar and there was a bar first
and it was the restaurant we only had
the restaurant for maybe I was about six
or seven that it was too big of a load
on my mother cuz at the end of the day
my mother had to cook the meals so my
mother had to cook but then somebody
would come in at 4:00 and serve the
meals and she had waitresses and my
mother would be behind the bar and I
stood alone one day my mother there was
a slow you know those doors that you
push huh Valvoline wasn't velvet it was
like a leather material with two windows
there was maybe my mother had 12 tables
maybe three of them had people on I was
about six I'll never forget that
a couple pulled up and the bar had like
15 people at the bar and two people
pulled up thank God you have a table for
two and they were like aren't you young
to be a Maitre D' and they would go fill
out me and I go nuts let me seat you
I'll never forget my mother was busy and
she goes what happened to those two
people and I know ice at them and she
goes you weren't supposed to see them
you supposed to see them at the bar I
gotta get him for two drinks before I
seen anybody in my restaurant I don't
care if it's packed or empty I gotta get
him for two drinks at the bar there's a
woman in 1969 telling it is yeah
and me going what the [ __ ] you talking
about then she goes west at 10,000 I
gave it I took it out I go he took it
out of my hand and she goes you just
lost it
you just paid for those two drinks and
she walked away from me and I cried and
I [ __ ] and remembered that lesson till
today
I remember that lesson yeah don't at
Benihana they should have been a guy
there
yeah that should have taken me and my
daughter oh you don't want you're too
young taking my daughter took my wife to
the bar and offered her a drink that's
that's principles those are the
principles I was raised in you know you
know many times I took my kid until I
[ __ ] YMCA pool and jumped in the pool
mate at three forty iPad time when I
first had mercy when I baptized mercy I
was 348 really yeah when I baptized
mercy I got big
I lost a bunch of way then I got big I
stick mercy that's why I'm saying with
no [ __ ] shirt on when she was six
months old I take it twice a week to
Mommy & Me swim it me and my [ __ ]
wife you know many times I saw Mexican
one little white kids in there oh yeah
now Tom Segura understand even New York
trying to feed your wife but here's the
beauty of it your wife and you were
there oh right don't want texting all
right tweeting and the kids are in the
pool why and they got a fat Mexican
woman you know barely [ __ ] species
and the [ __ ] dreamer she's a dreamer
she's looking out the window you know
waiting to bring the rest of them and
you never say yeah you do what are the
chances like that kids got no chance
you never built a bond a bond with your
child
yeah I still remember [ __ ] two feet
of snow falling into the York City I'm a
Cuban kid dawg two feet of snow waking
up my mother reeking of alcohol and her
getting dressed and pulling me down
[ __ ] Amsterdam Avenue
remember those sleds yeah with the Rope
pulling me back and forth for two hours
I was a kid with a hangover you know
what your check you know what Mercy's
chances are get me I'm the [ __ ] two
feet of snow with a hangover
niente zero you know I'm saying white
power
[Laughter]
these are the things that get at me that
parenting is really like cut out and
then now we got you know that whole
shooting with that [ __ ] Colorado you
know what happened right there was a kid
and then he had a 16 year old that was
born a female but she identified as a
man mm-hmm
I don't know maybe I'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
maybe I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] how old do
you have to be to drink 21 so you've
given a [ __ ] to 14 year old [ __ ]
pills because he tells you he's a woman
giving him [ __ ] pills it's happening
younger that the mind is not even
developed yet I'm not I'm not a [ __ ]
genius here I'm not a [ __ ] genius
here listen I did ass in the 14th I may
at any time walk into a [ __ ]
restaurant
and just [ __ ] my hair and wrought
against the wall I'm waiting for it is
dimension my future it has to be
I ate 20,000 hits of my foot not acid
let's pretend we're not even ad in the
[ __ ] angel dust in there before my
low fat [ __ ] mind was developed I
know I'm gonna have a problem down the
line I'm not a psychiatrist I don't know
nothing but you're telling me giving a
12 year old kid walking
titty pills [ __ ] pills you're gonna
give some kid [ __ ] pills at 12 and
that [ __ ] up his little mind they do not
know that that they that what the fourth
the 16 year old had a sitting quotas
[ __ ] mother because he's a [ __ ] he
identifies as a [ __ ] woman but he's
really a [ __ ] man if my kid Tom
Segura Murphy comes home and says to me
I identify as a man I will start
smacking up what you know I'm saying
yeah I identified as a savage I still
check the boxes [ __ ] mail
okay identifies the savage I rob people
I put people in trunks of cars I don't
give a [ __ ] I am a savage the I still
mark the Box gender male I like to put
other I'm a [ __ ] savage [ __ ]
animal but really you know how can you
Joey
give you a child I'm doing it they're
doing it to kids that are like seven and
six to give me titty stick to watch yeah
sorry like the watch the transition like
I'm no [ __ ] genius here but I want
you to think about this your little mind
isn't even develop come back when you're
24 oh you want to be a woman come back
when you're 24 go out there and live
like as a man at till you're 21 so you
mean to tell how old you have to be to
join the service
18 18 I don't know maybe I'm missing the
[ __ ] boat you know it's very maybe
they should put me in a [ __ ] menace
to do you know what I mean you have a
little kid to like I have a kid two kids
like kids say crazy [ __ ] to
and to like I think it's like people who
want to transition
obviously you receive like yeah go ahead
man but when it's like a child its I
have nothing but love for lgbtq I
understand it I understand it but I
think it's I understand it but I don't
think a child before the age of 18
understand
I don't I don't think so either I don't
think there's a grasp I think that when
they're 18 if they want to identify they
have to go through some type of program
and take some type of testing at the age
of eight nine ten eight nine ten you
don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about come on man
you don't know what you're talkin when
you're 21 if you take an i if you take a
great look at your [ __ ] life did you
even have a crew it's like I'm 21
you were just flapping your lips like I
was yeah of course do we just flapping
you were just picking up what people are
saying at different [ __ ] parties yeah
they're flapping what Samantha Lee yeah
you might can tell me it's um oh yeah
there you go okay I think you know think
of somebody shaved like ten for a week
here's the thing man think about if you
do start transitioning at a really young
age and then you're like 25 or 30 and
you're like oh [ __ ] like I didn't want
oh yeah I did it way too soon or even
you could even be younger you could be
19 and be like why did it you guys help
me transition at nine or 10 and then you
know there's there's already evidence of
that of people who have done that and
get suicidal you know go look at the
statistics transgender people at any age
that that made the conversion or the
journey or whatever it's called yeah to
be rude yeah you'll get the Ray there
suicide there yeah you know unhappiness
be them happy as a [ __ ] total as
it makes you think yeah I don't ever
like being unhappy I don't like it
anymore I was unhappy for a long time I
know I'm at an age where I know what
makes me happy I know what makes
together I know what I want to do is
that the best 50% it's a nearly fourteen
percent of adolescents reported a
previous suicide attempt but then for
the world for people to go from female
to male it's 50.8% and then from male to
female it's 41 points I don't know what
I'm talking about I'm a [ __ ] idiot
in these people's eyes and this is what
I live with that it's it's not about
it's common sense yeah I would think so
it's [ __ ] calm
since you have you know I'd love it when
they show the governor of whatever
dressing up like the KKK and putting
blackface huh at the age of 23 I hate to
tell you you're a [ __ ] idiot at the
age of 23 definitely your first year of
college you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] with with
eyeballs everybody I don't care what
kind of degree you have you have no life
experience No
you've been in the college you've been
in a dorm you've been whatever the [ __ ]
you have yeah yellow this Fri Friday
nights is always date night in my house
if I'm in town there's no comment on
that we leave at 6:30 we pick a
restaurant we take a ride well home by
9:00 9:30 it's no big deal
what about Sunday's you got on Sundays
no no I know I know the pollicis son
gave dinner with the family who goes out
on Sundays Joey who know who goes who
goes what type of person goes out on a
Sunday come they were just a Sunday
night well hire people no no no look
when you're a [ __ ] professional yeah
if you really want to sling dick and get
your dick sucked and let your balls on
fire if you really want a party it's
Sunday and Thursday night when I was
doing coke
Oh Sunday nights a good night to pick up
a piece ask if she's been saying no all
weekend yeah yeah she's been saying no
since Thursday she's been holding out
she went to Chico LaRue's house and
snorted blow you got a Sunday she's nice
too soft she's already taken 20 punches
to the head you don't say she's already
rose at McGowan McGowan she's bound to
say yes okay a couple [ __ ] drinks
couple bluebirds maybe a hot and
sleeping pill you getting your dick
sucked
you know Thursday night you know I never
understood when I was like 18 I figured
out not to go out on Friday nights
before I left for Colorado January of
1983 I was cut and it was driving my
friends crazy they couldn't understand
like what are you doing fry let you're
up to something what do you do go to a
gay bar watch TV because I went out
Thursday night got my dick sucked and
started bluff there is Friday nights are
for amateurs and Thursday is the best
Thursday's the best me
get down but back on the Sundays yeah
when you're partying Sunday's are good
but once you have a girlfriend and you
start going steady with them and
whatever think about what this country
was made up Sunday [ __ ] dinner yeah
four o'clock I don't give a [ __ ]
unless somebody's giving you a million
[ __ ] dollars I guarantee you look
look at statistics of people we dinner
together on Sundays
I'm one of the family stays together it
just makes sense I never had a family
for years I ignored this poor girl for
the first three years I did this poor
girl I was never home really never hope
I didn't want to come home because I was
a [ __ ] addict I was telling my wife
the other if I still snorted coke I'd be
on the road every weekend every will
[ __ ] the podcast I just be on the road
every weekend why not
that's the party would start on [ __ ]
Wednesday yeah it's the perfect [ __ ]
the road if you're an addict and you
want to keep it quiet the roads the way
to do it I mean eventually you're gonna
make mistakes and stand by an ounce of
coke for an undercover agent are you
gonna get herpes are you gonna look like
Mitch Hedberg eventually that's gonna
happen Bert yeah Burton's poor bird
leave her alone
he's lifting way to one on a little
Chinese kid with a camera he's worried
he's walking around Belgium and [ __ ]
like that
I having a good time I saw him last week
got so faith with Chinese I don't even
know his birth the Fighting's chat I
thought it was a fat [ __ ] and [ __ ]
and I looked it was burnt with some kid
that outfalls guy's [ __ ] head is
swollen Budweiser that [ __ ] Pete he's
all red oh no he sees a mess
I thought he was a fat chick I saw him
it was the fat chick lifting weights at
some skinny [ __ ] he's back right he's
back yeah he's rested he got back last
night
he's your song on Instagram yeah oh oh
god forbid he don't tweet about himself
oh he's like a [ __ ] fifth grader
unbelievable over here know what I'm
buying a shirt do you like that he was
at a bar he made a video of him at the
bar the other day that was just
hilarious Oh hanging out with people
yeah yes [ __ ] hilarious he really is
he walked that is my nightmare though he
did he'll tell the audience like let's
go to this bar the audience and then
he'll go party with the audience fr
Gabriele took the whole audience at
Denny's Christmas night that I think it
is that I could get into he told the
whole audience I'm reach a Denny's three
thousand Mexicans everybody
at Denny's Christmas night the way he
does those Christmas Day shows does he
really yeah he's a savage though he he
[ __ ] goes he must do 280 shows a year
still more I'm saying Gabe has no chill
at all just huge tweet last night no
[ __ ] all you [ __ ] I went to
Alaska it's so like he sold out the
whole state even the fishing poles they
just had fishing poles everybody left
that show what's the boat the boat was
docked what's the Alaska show he sold
over I believe it yeah he tweeted last
night check comics are missing out but
he never he never slows down
Gabe goes hard men Gabe goes hard and he
I mean obviously it works not saying he
shouldn't be saying like that remember
he started at an age with no Twitter
yeah and built that following that this
just you know I'm a Twitter Facebook guy
10,000 10,000 in Alaska yeah [ __ ] man
that's crazy
you know what guy you know you look at
these old bands like I totally one-time
by their respect take care of them for
example you know how hard it was to
break out of Boston
you had the Boston Celtics area you have
the Boston Bruins the Red Sox were God's
then right yeah dick but you had the
Celtics or whatever you got two tickets
for the something so you want to see
five guys with long hair yeah come and
that's they had Havlicek Joe Joe you
know yeah [ __ ] Russell you know that
whole [ __ ] dynasty how does a band
bus that without social media it's crazy
no Gabriel Sebastian Gabriel by the way
also like I'm playing some some big
venues now and sometimes you know
there's like artwork in the hallways I
keep texting them like I'll see in the
hallway like Gabriel Iglesias then I'll
look at the date I was like I'm saying a
pretty big theater year and it'll be
like 2010 and I'm like dude you were
doing this venue in 2010 he's like yeah
I think I did it first in like 2008 or
something like god damn I didn't realize
how long he's been you know moving that
many tickets it's a long time in to
maintain that for a decade is a big deal
it's a big deal
it uh I still remember the bicycle club
Gabe 35 hours on Thursday nights and you
had to get paid on Friday you gotta go
back on Friday and get your money in the
heat of traffic off the set
Jesus there was times you just to keep
the 30 photos I stole them when he lost
his virginity on the plane like the one
time in those days Rudy Marino booked
Wednesday in Tucson called Bugsy's and
you'd fly down every one is a three
comics a buck 50 apiece
you got a hotel room and you know like
six miles and food cuz the guy went 800
pounds that book the thing he had a lump
on his [ __ ] neck it was tremendous he
take it to the best Mexican places but
then they introduced his show name K
locals oh do you remember that yeah yeah
he blew up on that and enjoyed slope
Lopez helped might think I know the
whole story but he's been rocking in
since that did it it's really impressive
if you just want to study you know being
a successful stand-up what he's put what
he's done is it really is remarkable to
build that following before that social
me like build it off of like those shows
and comedy central stuff and like just
have that loyal of a following and make
it grow for tent-like you know he does
arenas and amphitheaters and [ __ ] now so
it's like it's gone the other way I
can't it was a couple miles ago but he
was like I remember coming to this city
when I got 30 people at the club and I
just I think was like 20 thousands there
was 20 people at the club and now I did
20,000 that's pretty cool you see I mean
his uh his special he shot it in Houston
where the Rockets play yeah and he sold
out two shows there you know I mean like
back-to-back 18,000 seat or whatever it
is 20 shows I mean that's 40,000 people
and it's really [ __ ] crazy man when
you study it dog I'll tell you why give
props to I had a conversation in one
night and this is exactly how the
conversation went to prison 98 when
Houston was the hottest club in the
country yeah and I was walking to our
factory who's walking in but Dane Cook
yeah
like Oh Dane how was Houston and he
looked at me and he goes it's a great
club just too many nights I gotta figure
out how to condense my nights and next
thing you know he was at that bar every
Tuesdays and they were just there to see
him in those days they didn't want to
see anybody else I don't give a [ __ ]
what anybody tells you yeah everybody
went that a-bomb to Dublin sir Dublin's
yeah early Dublin's you just went there
to bomb
I still remember watching three for
comics bomb I ate a bag of dicks
and I said I'm there's no reason to go
back there again just torch the room he
would destroy them he would it would
just be dude amazing time I had him on
last week on a podcast and we were
talking about that and I was trying
tell the listening and viewing audience
like because I used to go to those shows
I didn't get on I member asking Jade I
gave Jay Davis a VHS I was like he was
like yeah like looking past he's like
sure man like talking like to other
people I was like [ __ ] I gave my VHS
tape and I I sat through a few of those
shows Dane like the [ __ ] walls would
shake I remember sitting there being
like what in the [ __ ] man like it was so
destructive it might be like the hardest
I've ever seen anybody know I was there
I saw it and you it's not that you were
jealous it's that you would defeat it
yeah I want to go back like you like
there's no reason to come here I already
know this is danger oh I'm not gonna
tell a room one time right bomb like
that I was like [ __ ] there's like all
Mexicans and all Mexican comics and I
went up there like two three years in
just ate [ __ ] I tried to cow crowd work
and I was like hey what do you think
about this so who cares got offstage and
the guy the guy hosts it was like damn
like that was why I was wild how bad
like he was talking about it and then I
was like sitting back saying I was like
[ __ ] and then I go hey man so can I come
back you know like maybe in a month or
so he was like you'll come back here
like in front of everybody was like he's
gonna come back here I was like god damn
cuz he I just hate [ __ ] so hard I never
went back but you know I was asking for
it but I met you in 98 no no after that
no I wasn't even out of here when did
you start comedy Oh - OH - was when you
started yeah and when did Rogen go on
the tour that you opened oh seven that
man tour yep are you already in Ohio no
no I was I was out here I was living
here yeah and I and I opened for him on
that and then I really [ __ ] formal
like I met you the night before he shot
a special in Columbus so I remember he
invited me out Ari and then he was like
Oh Diaz couldn't make it so Diaz is
coming on another flight Diaz walks into
the hotel in his tracksuit he was like
dog I gotta tell you something
this [ __ ] [ __ ] on the flight he's
like I almost got arrested today and he
[ __ ] said that he was on a flight and
that he was first class and they put his
food down and the guy in the in front of
him lean back
so Joey shove DC and the guy was and the
guy leaned back again he goes eh you
[ __ ] lien on my food man so the guy
was like I think I did it again so Joey
stood up and went around and stood above
the guy and the guy was like hey man I'm
just like leaning back he goes you're
leaning back on my food and the guy like
went to adjust or like stand up and joy
put his hand on his shoulder and was
like you know you don't got to do
nothing right now just sit straight and
then when you got off the flight you
said there was to Columbus PD officers
on the jet bridge and they were like
Jose Diaz and you're like I got this
this wheat under my nuts and this is by
the way this is me meeting him I don't
know anything and then you go you said
you just were like very polite like oh
yeah no you know the guy this and that
you kind of talked him down and they
were like all right you know good to go
got off to like this guy was a total
[ __ ] you have a memory and a half I
did that was exactly how it went down
and here's the crazy thing like he kept
doing it to me like after I said to him
his chair is broken
his chair was broken to start off with
okay so now he would lean back
I really guys I really opened up as a
gentleman he was an LA [ __ ] he was like
a set designer he had that smell to him
as a casting director yeah yeah one
agency at a boutique agent yeah it was
one of those scumbags yeah those are the
worst and he looked at me like whatever
I putting my hand on his shoulder again
he's one of those [ __ ] people they
yelled assault yeah yeah so what I said
that's like you assault hot up and went
to the store this and now the store this
is giving me the Malou guy all the store
this is giving me the [ __ ] Malakai
and I'm like this is not gonna be good
yeah and I'm that those days had my
sleeve
pack your bag and I had and at this time
I was getting in trouble at airports
every other week every other week I was
having a beef at an Apple really just
between the cocaine and my attitude yeah
and it was just a bunch of things are
attributed to it and I'm a mom we got
off the plane the cops are waiting for
me and I'm stinking a reefer there's
after three hours even with the anti
stink bag the [ __ ] will leak out those
anti stick bags you could buy and they
really do some among you people they
sell now in Hollywood where they
wouldn't stink but after two hours the
weed was so pungent yeah then you could
smell on your body and the two cops
stopped me and the [ __ ] guy was
standing there going you know you should
put him in jail all this one like I
didn't do nothing go to jail I tried to
be a man explain something to you right
in front of cops I'm like but you were
too much of a [ __ ] an la [ __ ] and the
cops kinda like oh I get what's going on
yeah because they're blue collar guys so
he walked away
yeah and they held me there so we
couldn't be at the luggage together and
that was it but there's a God accepteth
these [ __ ] I don't know whether
he sent his son to kill Jesus
those Chinese I love these a Buddha I
don't know if he's a Hindu there's a God
guess what happened here later mmm I saw
that same [ __ ] cross going to Columbus
on a Friday with me are you serious and
I just eyeballed him and he made eye
contact to change that eye contact on
one time I want him to the bathroom and
what I did this time because went over
the stewardess first you see and I'm
saying yeah
so I went open chamber complan I love
your shoes
yeah you know I'm written if she's black
I'm ripping down the Beyonce poster they
go bananas and then we go way back oh
yeah I thought when they're black I go
listen when I get all them ripping the
Beyonce poster down they go [ __ ]
bananas
[ __ ] bananas come on dawg and always
get some because they're [ __ ] they go
[ __ ] bananas nuts they want to show
you the titties like that like that
would you grab me
that's how they got those [ __ ] poor
African women so on the walk back i said
hey remember me and dog he lost all the
color of his face there was no more
stewardess there was no Columbus cops so
I just sat like he was in row 3 a and I
was looking for B so for two hours I
just tapped my hand and stared at and
every time you look at me I was
eyeballing gone to Malou guys it was
tremendous
he got off that plane and ran I bet he
ran off that [ __ ] plant and I giggled
all the way that whatever because
there's a God in the [ __ ] sky yeah
I'm a [ __ ] you [ __ ] dummy actor that
way how was it gentlemen a couple weeks
earlier I'm going to north I always take
an aisle seat now don't say a word to
nobody how to play you don't talk to
them yeah I don't start it I don't ask
him where the weather nothing I said
nice that next to Berkeley last year the
whole flat I'm the same done to him till
we got off what'd you say I loved your
Philadelphia that's it
we walked off the plane one time it was
me Sebastian and John Legend sitting
right next to each other and talk to no
but only to talk to I need to take a
picture with nobody to do nothing I get
my [ __ ] treat this is not first class
this is United no LAX to Newark I'm
sitting there the plane lands the planes
about to land and I take my phone up and
I turn the phone up and the guy in the
window seat says look at me goes turn
the phone off a German guy there's two
German guys and next they were [ __ ]
me like if they talk L'Occitane you know
jew haters whatever the [ __ ] they are
and they're both sitting there [ __ ] a
hawk of each other the best person he or
whatever the [ __ ] they do it
so finally can you believe this he goes
huh not even excuse me yeah
sir you might get in trouble he goes
turn the phone off
and I go what
and he goes turn the phone off and the
guy in the middle go did you not hear
him turn the phone off I go
bro no [ __ ] do you think you're talking
to I don't have a [ __ ] time you're
doing Rico [ __ ] you and [ __ ] him and
they're both going wait till we get off
the plane we'll see you know we'll
[ __ ] see and your store the sling is
their problem and I go this [ __ ] hump
tried to tell you turn the [ __ ] phone
off and she said control your language
you know something no I'm not to control
my language you don't ever [ __ ] tell
somebody don't you you asked them and
the guy kept talking and finally I go
what if I got up and just kicked you
against that [ __ ] door right now cuz
you're in the last seat I wouldn't be
saying a word if I was you cuz if I
start swinging I could be a [ __ ]
madman why are you talking if you're in
the third seat in the [ __ ] aisle all
I see was holding your hands up and me
stopping on you that's all I see you got
a no-win situation
you could be Johnny Mme I get the first
drop way that that leg weighs 265 once
it goes in T I'm gonna keep putting my
leg and T and kicking you and you
[ __ ] Hitler buddy here so the [ __ ]
stewardess causes separates this cuz I
told him how long ago is this just had
it be last week now around that time
this was like an inch okay I kept having
the sopranos was hotter than hell yeah
at that time so I was having different
[ __ ] incidents every other [ __ ]
week some of them were good some of them
were people busting my balls about the
soprano that you were the guy
technically yeah it was just like I'm
ongoing so now they separate us on the
plane cuz I told the guy what if I
started kicking you right now we're
gonna go are you retired you can't be
that [ __ ] stupid talking all that
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] third seat I
wouldn't say a word I'd wait trying it
in the hallway well I got an even chance
but that's how stupid you are
so they the stewardess comes over she
gets me up and sure enough you got a
city until the police have been notified
what god
damnit so now I'm aggravated cuz my
friend those days we had no dough you
gotta have your friends circle like a
[ __ ] scoots around the airport so I'm
like you know my friends waiting for me
think Allah you're the last guy to board
your booty on boarding with the pilot so
we get up and I forgot I'm in New Jersey
as soon as I see the cops all I had to
do is get there first
all I got to do is get to that cop purse
and let him hear me so that's exactly
what I did
I want to right up to the complan go
this [ __ ] guy the cops like what's go
it's a perm here this [ __ ] guy trying
to tell me they're trying to fall off
with my guys thought it would his
[ __ ] white [ __ ] well we the phone is
not supposed to be turned on my shut up
I'm like first of all you're the [ __ ]
away team [ __ ] once I said that
it was our I go you're the away team you
got no say in this this is Jersey you
don't tell somebody from Georgia turn
the [ __ ] phone oh [ __ ] this guy [ __ ]
him don't ever [ __ ] talk to someone
like that the cops like he's got you
there yeah so the one cop walked them
and the one cop walk with me and I just
kept saying [ __ ] it's gonna be the
waking [ __ ] don't ever forget
that [ __ ] we got you I can make these
guys turn you in and rape get a death
you're missing right now this could be
like Pulp Fiction at the end when you
call the two hillbillies yeah yeah this
is juries these two cops could take on a
long ride and you'll never come back
we saw him evacuating the plane Newark
and that's it that's it we don't know
nothing no seriously I had a bag blunt
your insolence I forget from the
instance seriously one time I'm [ __ ]
walking on a noise head but with a bag
of reefer and there's ten cops coming at
me with those dogs oh [ __ ] I had him go
into a [ __ ] men's bathroom take the
weed out and I hit him the toilet paper
roll you don't me dawg and I went back
out there and they're barking and [ __ ]
barking all around I [ __ ] took the
[ __ ] bag back putting my nutsack and
ran outside I was having the time I was
out somewhere snow gonna [ __ ] join
the cop pulled up on me in an airport
I'm outside smoking the [ __ ] joint
and they're like what do you think
you're doing they pulled me aside I got
pulled over in Detroit one time so what
happened when like a DEA
really yeah coming from Miami to Detroit
please so when you were smoking though
because you know one of my friends I
know like the whole world you know has
changed with weed one of my friends is
so casual that like whenever we're
traveling somewhere he's just like
smoking on any Street without ever
looking or anything like you don't even
think about it at all I don't think I'm
really if you're a cop and you're really
concerned with marijuana I'm not
concerned with I'm pulling you over and
talking to you I listen I would not I
don't have the decency to go to your a
park where kids are playing and sparkup
I'm not talking about yeah I'm talking
about go outside right now spark up a
joint I've had that's for 20 years
you always were like a for the war
before the [ __ ] paper what did that
cop say to you when you said what you
think you're doing what are you smoking
and you're like well I got a little weed
I get anxious at the airports and
bye-bye and they just said turn it off
we throw it away that was it that's it
just be honest with them don't show more
[ __ ] weed shirt don't tell him about
your Fourth Amendment to have Liberty on
your business just tell him the truth
but did you know always like if someone
was like that's me I'm playing I would
have anxiety about yeah I want to yell
at them and I would think about what I
wanted to say but I would never go back
no I'm gonna don't you guys do that say
that [ __ ] to me there's a way to speak
to people you can't tell somebody a
definite [ __ ] phone can't [ __ ] did
you say excuse me sir I don't think they
want you to have the fallout then it's
my decision after that I'm still gonna
turn it on I love when the old days mate
said it's gonna fall on on the plane how
do you know yeah that's for white people
to believe check your phone I've had the
phone on the whole [ __ ] time
everyone's focused on ya and they try to
scare you like someone yeah the pilot
says there's a phone on and people would
double check and I know my father I've
never been good listen let's be honest I
told somebody the story let's be
strictly completely honest with each
other well I got thrown out of Catholic
school my mother made me a deal at the
age of ten she goes you could take care
yourself where I could take a
if I take a it's gonna be on the [ __ ]
communist to Cuba most if you take care
and you don't slip up
we don't ask no questions so she was
already raising me to be on my health
yeah my wife of 19 years who I love with
all my heart those two things about me
don't ask me where I'm going and just
pretty much don't ask me anything I'll
tell you yeah if you want to keep your
relationship as a friendship with me
don't ask me no questions that's it
because I'm not gonna tell you the truth
even if I'm gonna murder somebody I'll
tell you whatever yeah man she goes
where you going to see a man about a dog
that's my common sense to people what
does that mean don't ask yeah I'm gonna
store what's the big [ __ ] plan it is
my pet peeve man
it is the questions because I've been
raised without it and now you know I've
been having a problem with certain
situations I don't like when people try
to push it out don't push it on because
you're not gonna get no one if there's
anybody who does what he wants to do
from the morning tonight it's me and
I've been doing it since I was 10
sorry you're not gonna change me you
know I could tell you thousands of
examples told you're not gonna lock me
in I don't like being locked in I'll
tell you two days before if you keep
bugging me I'm not gonna do it ask me
I'll give you a time in a day and I'll
[ __ ] be there it's it's it's weird to
explain the people and now that we're
parents what time guy you know how much
I appreciate just to get you for an hour
Tom no you have not one child but two
child two children people don't really
understand the value of your time oh
yeah it's the most of the how many
stupid requests you get every week from
people a lot and you try to be fair and
honest with them yeah but unless you
have a child you can't comprehend it how
do I know cuz I didn't comprehend
Ralphie when Ralphie come to town I go
hey man let's smoke pot me go no I gotta
take my kid to the zoo with all the
money you have
go to the zoo that was my thinking yeah
that's not my thinking anymore it
happened cuz you know you know it's not
about money it's just sit with them
watch it I thought I sat one of this
morning for an hour before I came here
playing that [ __ ] out of the [ __ ]
yard
I'm motherboard of the whole [ __ ] kit
yeah did the porch of Joey kit yeah the
horseshoes the [ __ ] thing where they
have to throw up and land in the circle
I did all that [ __ ] this morning then
cost us a dime they just want time now
they do this might play with you and
people really don't understand that
concept anymore you know
I have to have rules I have to have I
got the store Tuesdays Thursdays and
Saturdays
what can you confirm that you won
because I got a wife and a kid dog yeah
and they're more important than your
stupid [ __ ] night that's why they're
more important you want me to tell the
truth yeah they are I don't give a [ __ ]
about your stupid [ __ ] night it's
just something you know can you come to
Marina del Rey and do a podcast no I
happy honestly you know that's four
hours now my thing is no the most things
that's four hours during the week I
gotta be back here every day by 3:30
thumps Agora I'm at attention like I'll
you show those Chinese people they stand
up they see the Koreans how they're out
there they don't move a muscle
yeah well then when the [ __ ] Kim Jung
Woon was talking that's me at 3:30 I got
a master and she's six
oh she's six I try to watch 15 minutes
of World News Tonight with David Muir
mm-hmm and then I do whatever she wants
to do which three days a week is Muay
Thai no and then the other two days is
swim and today's woman I should be
swimming right now you see they gave the
boot by the way the CBF guy he's out CBS
anchor which one forget his [ __ ] name
he did the nightly news there they were
given the gig to the lady from the
morning show there's swap swapping it
out the black chick no mm-hmm the she's
like a white middle-aged lady if I could
forget her name but she's taken over the
CBS Evening News I mean he's a mirror
xavc but I'm saying like that's it so
it's a big switch up man I think I asked
you a question how have you maintained
being so cool Oh ass cop we is
you have a great career going I don't
know how many [ __ ] that I mean
Netflix has a poster you in their office
and you go to Netflix office like the
president comedy has a picture you dick
like a little kid Michael Jackson little
[ __ ] dick it looks like one of those
chicha which as those eight little
sausages they come in a can
why people call them via the sauce yeah
that's what my nipple look like the file
therapy one time my [ __ ] nipple
[ __ ] look like a cheetah
I want the crowd therapy in Columbus
Ohio the black guys like I don't know if
you are going there Doug a muffler
hasn't been in to have weeks cuz you're
gonna Karl therapy in Ventura yeah it's
every three minutes I'm in this one
warms up when you with it like their dad
one in their early like 10 15 oh that
was the longest three minutes of my life
I threw more punches and Donald's around
it thought I was throwing [ __ ]
punches from my lines that were you
doing there yeah what are you gonna do
what options do you have but you move I
go in the song is three and a half
minutes I put on slaves and bulldozes
and I always have to PAP you can't have
bad music
now go crazy yeah yeah I have Madonna
you got to move yeah I put on that get
into the groove yeah well burning up for
your love and I'm dancing so when I go
during the week now you have to go to a
weird time like Sunday's you're going at
12:15 you're gonna freeze to death in
there so first minute is so easy so what
I do is lock the first 30 seconds for me
is just standing I take the robe off I
hang it up and I just stand there and I
let the cold hit me and I focus on
breathing that's the most important
thing about the crowd chamber that they
don't tell you that's why as soon as I
went into a crowd chamber the first hand
there was called dr. police because in
dr. police's book it says about the
agent 13 to 16 is when you lose your
natural ability to breathe something
happens traumatic and your timing goes
along so you forget out inhale through
your nose and breathe out through your
mouth
that thing forces you if not you will
have like a panic attack in that yeah so
the first 30 seconds or you go you just
don't mind
you breathing listen to the music and
just get your breathing in and know that
for three minutes
you can't stop I go on there for three
and a half minutes do you really yeah
three and a ham
I started at 3:15 you started at 3:50
yeah the first time when I would 3:15 I
thought was in the [ __ ] I start with
- I started at 3:15 and worked myself to
3:30 god damn 3:15 I know the turnaround
can start putting my robot ok I always
leave the one arm [ __ ] up to force me
to adjust to the stress like if it's
cold I want to get a just sir I just
don't I always leave the arm tuck yeah I
don't understand from the saying I think
so yeah they give me a hard at time to
get out of it ok sorry 3 once it says 30
seconds
I throw punches for another 15 I count
them off and in my head I stand there
and I very real actually take the thing
off I don't want to do that because now
you're creating panic in yourself that's
true so I forced myself to take it off
as cold as I am pull the sleeve down and
put warm arm in one arm and when it
turns off she opens the door I come out
and the chief [ __ ] tests my body but
I work it I love that feeling when you
leave it's worth it for it man the build
I might go today because I'm hungover
yeah I'm hungover just you know sleep on
oh yeah yeah like I didn't edible the
other night that was so [ __ ] strong
that my wife woke me up at 22 to on the
couch and I thought she was you had a
look on your face like I was a demon I
know I was I passed that was dreaming
about food you were like when she woke
nipples I felt like I was having a dream
about [ __ ] she wasn't a kitchen I filled
up a water bottle in 2002 and I walked
straight to the kitchen open up the
[ __ ] cabinet and there was a half a
jar of Pringles I just let it bring one
I just ate the [ __ ] Pringles don't
have made a ham and cheese sandwich I
hate that and I went right to bed I was
so [ __ ] high like the next morning I
woke up and I saw the American cheese
because when they say that the torture
he puts paper in it uh-huh
I sorta thought oh wait the cheese left
oh my god I hate the [ __ ] cheese less
how strong was the animal
100 milligrams is stronger than that oh
my god
I took told to New York to shoot this
movie and I took one of them one night
when I had insomnia slept like a baby
and then the other I took on the flight
back
you took the hundred milligram on the
plane fly back I started freaking out
that the plane was gonna go down when
they pulled the plane over to the side
because of the rain in the Midwest and
they kept saying if we don't leave in 30
seconds in 30 minutes we're probably
gonna have to cancel flights up tomorrow
morning i'm i as a [ __ ]
and i'm thinking maybe I took the wrong
plane and I switched and maybe because I
was supposed to leave sadly you're out
of your mind at this point out of my
mind I'm an hour in with earphones the
plane was at the gate for half-hour and
they made a double go up and then we
drove around all over [ __ ] New York
City with Kennedy Airport will cutting
off ubers I'm like what the [ __ ] this is
plane going and I saw a little Arabs
pulling over to the side [ __ ] you I'm
the driver Thanks we're in that [ __ ]
plane after a half-hour I'm thinking
more in the air this man now DIRECTV you
know MIT yeah that blue has yeah the
DirecTV yeah so I'm not watching the TV
I'm focused on the radio and I'm
thinking we're in the area and I open up
I see 20 other plans I don't wanna [ __ ]
off we have been driving for an hour I
don't know when the airport
we're flying around for [ __ ] an hour
and I'm like what the [ __ ] is this pilot
going I thought were in the air in it
I swear that my daughter's grave I was
so high I thought we were in the fight I
took 20 milligrams on my last flight to
New York and that was too [ __ ] much
for me really do something new first do
something I took 50 on the flight then I
[ __ ] up I was [ __ ] up to those
little stars those green stars I bought
the 10 milligrams apiece yeah I took cuz
I bought those too yeah you control your
eye
yeah the capsules tripoli thank god
tinfoil podcast give him a shout-out my
man Sam Tripp I called him Sunday
fighting crime I go triple-a neither
I need another Bob Louis things he
showed up with a case
they're good Sammy
yeah he gets down so [ __ ] now the guy
goes all flights going south available
to take off but all flights going
westbound are stuck we're on hold
oh and now this animals getting stronger
and stronger now I'm thinking to myself
I was really supposed to leave at 5:30
3:00 in the morning and get to LA and
8:30 that was my original flight B being
the [ __ ] pig to the Hammond I gotta
get out of here okay I wanna I want to
be home in the daytime for her tomorrow
yeah necessarily getting home tired let
me go home I'm on that [ __ ] plane
comes to girl and I'm like you know when
you I was okay this is how people die
this is how people die and this is how
people lose bets all week you wanted the
Mets at the last minute you call the
Yankees and you lose the metro gonna win
that was your first [ __ ] option why
did you switch yeah so I started
thinking that way holy [ __ ] my daughter
Lee my family my friends I was that high
dam and I'm like how can I get off this
planet
Dawson he goes alright we've been
approved oh my god dammit as the plane
was taking off I know I can't even
listen I was so high I couldn't even
hear music no more yeah like the music
was good making me panic so I know do
your phone's off and I go I'm just gonna
watch TV without the sound yeah it's
like what a mistake and press CNN in
desk and it shows the plane went down
off one Alamo Bay oh [ __ ] I personally
and I'm like oh [ __ ] it a plane went
down today and I'm good yeah I'm saying
my place he took it yeah so how is
asking are you keeping your head with
all the great success you've had the
last couple years because you're still
one of the sweethearts of my world yeah
I don't know man I mean I think I think
happened at having a family keeps you
grounded right like we have kids that
you know your family you just that's
like the most important thing and then I
don't know I feel lucky I feel fortunate
to have opportunities you know I mean to
get to play the shows the big shows and
you just feel like you know I think also
maintaining working the same way that I
always worked
is for me like comforting you know I
mean like when I was like a 1200 1500
dollar a week Act I would just go on the
road do my shows I had like a routine
right like just and I'm and I do the
exact same thing
I just bigger venue but I I prepare for
touring the same way I tore the same way
I think that keeps me like I just think
of it as the same thing as the $1500
week at you know I mean like prepare the
same way just more people are at the
show I'm which you traveling though it's
um
like the last few weeks were super busy
so now I'm off for a few weeks I got an
easy easy week next week I have a
Riverside theater show and then Saturday
Vegas and that's it fly home Sunday
morning and I'm done first so that's the
only show for the next few weeks and
then it picks up again in June but then
I have July three weeks in July off and
then August September October November
are pretty busy like at least how's your
disease December's III do one thing at
the beginning of it like four shows and
then I do New Year's in Hawaii when do
you should know special November we're
at in Austin at Austin City Limits no
[ __ ] yeah good for you yeah I'm excited
I'm excited that's been how arrived for
you man it has its day one yeah it's
been training for all of us yeah
everyone this whole circle of friends
like the way that this has turned out is
nuts
you know I mean there's like it's
expanding but like the the circle that I
consider like you know that I'm close to
buddies with you Jo re Bert like what's
happened is with podcasting and with
stand-up this is the biggest era of
standup ever stand-ups never been more
popular saying across the board you know
like I was talking to a promoter last
week about it could you forget I forget
he's like you know like 15 years ago he
goes do you know how many theater acts
there were in comedy he's looked like
five
you know it was like Cosby Carlin you
know whoever like Seinfeld big yet to be
like a [ __ ] huge well-known name to
be a theater comic he goes now he goes
pull up any theater list he's like
there's [ __ ] 200 comedy shows a year
at these theaters so it's the best time
to have ever have things going well for
you in comedy
we've never it's it's definitely I mean
I can't reference it from memory but
like it's got to be crazier than the 80s
boom that people talked about where do
you want to take it where do you see
yourself in five years do you want to be
like Gabriel doing arenas and Kevin Hart
do you feel like I mean I'm kind of
conflicted in that like I've I've done
four parts in movies in the last year
you know from a big-budget film all the
way down to like a micro budget film you
just shot a film also recently I just
shot a movie two weeks ago I had like
five days or something six days here in
town here in town which is thank god the
best I like movies way more than I like
television I love I love the whole
layout of movies I like that movies have
a schedule and a rap date and then it's
over so you can see like I love the
finality of a movie schedule I love the
storytelling aspect of it I just like it
before you got here we and I were
talking about scheduling I have a big
problem with calmly scheduling anymore
we have a big cop problem with comedy
touring in this town and how it ends I
have a big [ __ ] problem with it I
always have I do not as a comic my
opinion ever start comedy to be on the
road 50 [ __ ] we see it oh you're not
at all not 40 not you've any perspective
though it's just they want yeah I did
not like oh I did not like it if you
live in [ __ ] Hollywood we live in a
Hollywood for a reason let me tell you
what the reason is okay
the reason is do I want the Joey Diaz
show at the end of the day if you really
sit here and think about it Tom Segura I
know you sold the show last
and I sold the show I decide I don't
want a [ __ ] show okay and neither do
you
you know why because it sucks the blood
alley and it turns into a vampire
now if chichi bust each had a show and
he wants to make me a janitor and he
guarantees me six episodes out of ten
episodes I can till ten weeks of how
they worked and for ten weeks I shoot
that TV show I do my podcast and I work
on at the store uh-huh when that show
wraps I go on the road
fresh fresh you go fresh you do that for
a year or two this is the way I got when
I got here when I got here it was
completely different than what it is now
then you did your ten episodes again and
guess what somebody offered you a movie
yeah so now somebody called you and said
from April 8th to May 6 we shoot this
movie we'll have the dates canceled
comedy yeah it's off the [ __ ] plate
do not bother me do not talk to me we
have nothing to talk about
so now instead of you working constantly
year round because where do you work out
your material for a Netflix special on
the road yeah so now they get to see it
again
that doesn't make sense to me no that
doesn't make sense to me that I turn on
your Netflix special and I know 20 out
of the 45 minutes that you're saying
doesn't make sense to me never made
sense to me I want to see your special
go oh I've never heard this from top to
[ __ ] bottom he said that when I saw
him a couple weeks ago on Cleveland yeah
I don't want that I don't want that I'd
rather do those then wrap yourself
around three weeks and clubs that nobody
will [ __ ] see yeah but they don't
matter I don't want to say what cities
or nobody gets insulted and then you
shoot your [ __ ] special and then
after you shoot your [ __ ] special you
go on the TV show for 10 weeks and put
the pen back on it get a [ __ ] feather
with the chicken blood out and now it
all balances out and at the end of the
year we'll not broke down on the stand
up you're not burnt down in the movie
because when you wrap them over you're
like thank god this is over yeah yeah
okay I don't give a [ __ ] of your work
with Olivier
after six weeks of long days and driving
and whatever you know he's [ __ ] sick
of it TV I'm shooting a movie in New
York you just said the magic words you
know again I don't mean to insult our
body big difference between a set no I
and a set in New York big difference you
will eliminate the kunti aspect there's
no managers or agents on that set now
the sound we're going on oh yeah they
don't give a [ __ ] of your Olivier you
ain't getting on there okay so it's just
a director writer situation with
producers and they work in New York
nobody stops us this time when you get
that why then it's so brilliant there's
none of that [ __ ] nothing you just shoot
go the last two or three things I've
shot have been television and I gotta be
honest and I'm not sounding like I'm
trying to be as honest with the audience
yeah you as I can on the ride home I
wanted to put a gun to my throat TV yeah
TV is something that we don't want it's
sold to us they sell us a number they
tell us what you're gonna make per
episode our dick gets hard then by the
third week you're losing your mind yeah
because you have a college kid telling
you what's funny [ __ ] did you did you
do Philadelphia with Bill Byrne that
time when I was getting thrown bagels
that no yeah
shut your [ __ ] mouth [ __ ] you and you
sang that live watching [ __ ] funky
[ __ ] ass okay swap you with your MADtv
you know when I was a fight day that I
watched silently that's not funny and
that's what your ween done we're
bringing the heat waiting Chappelle
canceled the Chappelle show do you think
he canceled enemies on crack no because
eventually get sick and tired of people
who don't know your craft telling
telling you about your [ __ ] craft
that's the worst okay yeah when you do
TV after the third episode they're
selling you [ __ ] that you've never even
heard them but I have two kids yeah but
we want you to have a boy and a girl no
one kids missing an eye and the other
kids are [ __ ] [ __ ] you like I
didn't want that that's not what Thomas
ago is about that's why we have a hard
time with TV yeah
that's why the movie bit this movie I'm
working on I'm loving it right now and
that was a schedule I was brought up on
yeah like what to live in LA look the
willows
look those comics are there dad
you know what I'm thinking of the only
thing that really sucks about feature
business movies is like the business of
it is horrible
like trying to get something going is
like a [ __ ] for yourself yes like
Jamaica Tom Segura movie [ __ ] it's
worse I got bad news feeling good news
yeah that's all great Danny and we try
yeah yeah and look we all want to sell a
show and be like louis c.k we get to
edit it and yeah myself and i'll do all
that [ __ ] you know what the chances are
that yeah that's six dudes they do it
that way and they gotta be in love you
and those are the people i mean louis
c.k was a funny guy that got that
privilege they're privileged they give
those people the unfunny ones
yeah you know like I said all I want to
do at this point my life you got a
recurring job for me on a job on show
you create I'm in labor that comes in
with underwear on I hate your wife in
the face with a dick nothing to do with
you yeah you move on from show to show
and over the look at these people that
are worthless look at every year there's
a new show on Fox once you just
cancelled three shots yeah you just put
on three shows aren't the same anymore
thank God they don't mean anything don't
mean anything how many shows they cut
yes all the time man every week no
variety cut I guess I sort of variety on
Twitter they must have cut dirty shows
and you know the other crazy thing is
you used to know there used to be no
such thing as somebody being like Yemma
on this show you would go like what show
they say the name of the show you pick
oh I know that show dude now people say
shows I'm like what's that they're like
that's in its sixth season I'm like I've
never heard of that he doesn't matter
yeah you know when I got the longest
shot I realized that TV didn't matter
people would tell me they don't want to
talk to people on TV they want to talk
to people who are in the movies yeah I
believe in one thing in stand-up comedy
first of all I like being fresh all I do
stand-up yeah now I really love being
fresh I really love wanting to go out
there and hug the people after the show
once you don't want to hug the people
after the show take pictures of them
don't do it you don't really want to do
this you know I'm not saying every
weekend I'm saying
I don't want it to be I believe it with
Winston Churchill says you know when you
go from area an area with excellence
I like podcasting because I don't have
to go out that extra weekend look I like
movies because they're like that you get
to do several different things and
you're fresh for all of them if you told
me right now Joey I picked up a shelf
for ten weeks I'm definitely right into
six I'm mentally prepared for that and
I'm excited for that I'm excited to
drive the Fox I know where I'm gonna eat
bagels I know I'm gonna do jujitsu in
the days we work late I know where I can
kick box I have a friend that loser you
know I'm saying yeah
so you turn it into your life I don't
want to shoot a fox show if my agents
calling me saying why don't you book a
Friday that week because I don't know
what's gonna happen I don't know what's
gonna happen
let's not book anything so we can avoid
the drama so we know where we are for 10
weeks that was all I ever wanted I want
this to be broken up I do not want to be
on the road for broke and didn't go on
the road all that [ __ ] he does it
because he's got a vault downstairs yeah
he's gotta do it the right way he did
two shows he's got it like really down
workwise he really only works where he
wants to work when he wants to do it
there's a big difference between being
hot and then one day you go cold like
the language we spoke about before yeah
no yeah and now you gotta walk there to
keep the lights on yeah it's two guys
that's a grind the guys you see on
tugboats now what do you call the ship's
crew ships those tugboats they're really
hang them there's gonna be a bunch of
Brodie's the next couple years boats
every weekend they had to come back with
a new Brody we're gonna be having
celebrations on ships for [ __ ] years
cuz you could just take so much of that
that cruise you walk out of your room
and you see three people yeah you just
that's the Brody [ __ ] that's like
that Scientology boat yeah that got back
last week cuz of these those poor
[ __ ] that ship [ __ ]
can you imagine that's how you know how
fortunate we are all right we taught my
feet touch the ground the more
I'm pissed I'm thinking God do you
really I swear to God that gratitude
[ __ ] is actually very everyday affect
every day first of all I'm on the cruise
ship
yeah I'm not gonna Long Beach get on the
ship lay with a bunch of mortadella who
goes on the cruise ship
we were going to cruise ship I've been
on I don't like it no yeah I've been on
at one time the cruise to Nowhere my
parents liked it you have please sit him
down and talk the next time you want a
cruise ship I'll get a [ __ ] I'll get
off six before black guy to throw you
off I swear the guy right then curry
sound I'll never find your body
I hate basketball I don't like you get
the measles everybody gets the measles
you get VD everybody gets VD that that
ship goes down ain't only amount of the
Caprio now paint only another cabin
ain't no chubby chicken here tonight
Kate Winslet she's hotter the [ __ ] throw
that [ __ ] that movie with a [ __ ] out
yeah
with hardly a child she shows a puss you
got a beautiful [ __ ] [ __ ]
good-looking chase got that how do we
tuck on the [ __ ] and [ __ ] things
really would am under [ __ ] when they
click don't come out how do you like do
you like it like slim and neat or do you
like a little meat to it I like a little
meat directly I was telling Kate quickly
she got mice body but no [ __ ] it looks
like cardboard on there and I'm saying
if I suck a [ __ ] or universal come on I
need to meet Danny I need that click the
Bijou you like a piece of Kalamata you
would chew on that Clinton you like it
stuff like calamari
that's how it I don't want calamari
tough yeah when I eat [ __ ] I want that
you know if you buy today girlie yeah
let me bite it you gotta bite it from
time to time what about you are you
eating personally don't even get me
please
we've been off this subject for months
leave the kid alone
yeah leave because there's no other
place please I don't chew on it yeah
that that's why you're single
cuz if you a [ __ ] the right way you
have twenty [ __ ] around you're a
chubby dude
chubby dude should always have twenty
[ __ ] because they eat that thing like
it's their Last Supper
you go down there you're scared you
don't want to lick the ass or you don't
want to open the cheeks
you never eat ass no really I don't want
oh that's gonna coach me though last
night took my wife there
yeah man took my well yeah but good oh
yeah
yes rice and bean how was that fart I
don't bring them now they go gotta eat
the ass I don't please beemo beemo
hey by the way I'm very flattered how
often I get tagged that you're my twin
oh thank you I don't know you're I lost
like 50 pounds but I need to lose some
weight
nice Tom Segura I don't want to take any
more your time on a Monday morning you
got home and feed the [ __ ] kids where
are you next weekend I will be in Las
Vegas at the cosmopolitan nice yeah and
then I got um I got Big Show the only
thing with tickets left is a June 2nd
the Late Show at the Chicago theater
it's a Sunday I got two shows there that
night the night before is Detroit and
saintly those are all sold out so the
Late Show June 2nd in Chicago come to
the Chicago theater it's a 9:00 p.m.
show anybody June 2nd yeah if I had the
balls and send the Juara prison to like
the [ __ ] theater on fire for having a
second show the [ __ ] devil you should
just take him the money from Sunday and
ride high now go get a [ __ ] beef
steak sandwich is sitting there like a
[ __ ] Bob out all day with a cup
looking for people to come on a Sunday
night in Chicago and I got shame a dick
it off for me what am I gonna do they
got a they got a Tom Segura calm
something like that yeah Tom's to God I
found a beautiful wife last tour great
man yeah she's great with Hungarians in
the world she loves Yuri Hungarian
friends she's one of them she's one of
them Christina right now huh you've
always said it right what's that you
said it right this time
what something I don't even know like
where Steve Christine sometimes gar
Christine and we always laugh about it
she goes nuts
is there a Tom cigar.com yeah doctor got
comm slashed or has all the dates some
seguro man Europe all that [ __ ] Europe
I'm doing your opportunity are you
leavin that's October what do they do
Isis [ __ ] function he has don't come
textmate really [ __ ] birth crisis right
so he go he's going back to Australia
he's gone Australia yeah with those
kangaroos together put that kangaroo
dick
I'll never be the same if you thought
you look Chinese before what do you see
him when he comes back man yeah I swear
the guy thought he was a fat chick
anyway I want to thank our spot to thank
my man Tom Segura and the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want that you
guys were real quick picking a reliable
CBD company is like pulling [ __ ]
teeth okay but those days have ended
lucky for you [ __ ] uncle Joey
found CBD line tremendous they make CBB
products from start to finish
CBD Lian has you covered it comes in
vape cartridges and a shadow and if
you're not into smoking they got
attention you put under your tongue your
[ __ ] tip-top Magoo their products are
clean Bobby and they aren't like the
fakes that you see at the [ __ ] liquor
store making false accusation is this
[ __ ] like that so do me a favor
go to CBD lyon calm and check out their
third-party test results and you'll be
[ __ ] flattened let me tell you
something the best and they got
tremendous raspberry gummy bears and
orange ones I don't know if they have
anything left but jump on them do me a
favor go to CBD line comm and on the way
out press Church and check out and get
20% off who's better than you guys in
the stem you'll be healthy
you'll be fitting they don't take you
for an arm in a [ __ ] leg number two
listen Memorial Day is around the corner
and you want to get your dick sucked but
you got that [ __ ] bush of hair it's
dry it's brittle your nut smell like
[ __ ] hummus and then you wonder why
your [ __ ] single well you got to help
yourself you got to [ __ ] raise your
percentages are getting [ __ ] and how do
you do it by having a beautiful dick
okay
I mean if you're gonna send a dick pic
you can't send it with hair and my thing
is a great by the way
manscaped is tremendous all right they
got precision tools for your family
jewels if you get what I'm saying
manscape has redesigned the electric
razor they invented the lawnmower
I had Hellraiser with skin-safe
technology so you won't Nick your dick
or snag your [ __ ] nutsack cuz you got
to go easy on the helmet guys that's all
God gave you this bad boy will leave you
clean smooth and pain-free plus it's
rechargeable and easy to hold and you
get on the nooks and cranny's if you're
a fat [ __ ] you got more rolls than
[ __ ] Dunkin Donuts you got to pick up
cuz hair comes out everywhere these days
manscape will get your bean bag looking
as smooth as a [ __ ] egg and I'm gonna
let you in on a little secret all right
if you trim the hedges that [ __ ]
death pole look a lot bigger for you
trust me I've been working it for years
now at manscape calm you get everything
you need to make your ball shine keep
your dick looking good and your balls
smelling fresh because that's the most
important thing if your balls don't
smell fresh you ain't gonna have no
friends so if this is the first time you
consider manscaping we got a deal for
you all right we got a thing called the
perfect package it comes with a lawn
mower and a safety razor plus the crop
preserver especially formulated
deodorant so your balls don't stink I
said it your balls stink and the Reviver
a tremendous sprint that tones and
refreshes your nutsack and your dick
stick to keep it nice and [ __ ] cool
now do me a favor the church family you
get 20% off 20% off 20% off your first
order when you use promo code shirts CH
you are ch4 you stupid [ __ ] at manscape
calm again manscaped calm cold church
and if you order the perfect package you
ready for this they're gonna throw a
little travel bag for you I got one at
the house I got my [ __ ] raises in
there got a little bit of weed just in
case the bag falls off the ship whatever
the [ __ ] it is they got your covers if
you're the perfect package don't throw
the free travel bag in that's manscape
com use promo code church for 20% off
your first order keep your [ __ ] balls
tween I want to thank my brother Tom
Segura I want to thank the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys for always having our backs you bad
[ __ ] I love you to all my heart
we'll be back Thursday morning ready to
sling dick and give our bubblegum
don't forget June [ __ ] 7th the
Fillmore New Orleans
June 8 the tabernacle in that lanta
tickets are on sale
well the Joey Diaz dotnet and let's get
this [ __ ] party started I'll see you
then get take this [ __ ] melee it's
Monday